things are getting pretty wild my
friends very wild Greg Abbott governor
of Texas says that 10 other states have
deployed National Guard to Texas to
defend the border and we're hearing
reports that private citizens in various
capacities are making their way to Texas
there are many people prominent uh
personalities saying do not go to Texas
fearing Another January 6 type incident
I don't know what's going to happen I
think this one should be left up to Greg
Abbott and the National Guard and law
enforcement and should be done through
all the legal channels they're going
through if National Guard are being
deployed I think it's probably a safe
bet to say private citizens shouldn't go
anywhere near this in in in reference to
any kind of conflict I can't I can't you
know tell people what they should or
shouldn't do if you're a private citizen
you can go where you're allowed to go
but I definitely think it's important to
say there's a lot of danger right now
and Greg Abbott is walking a fine line
and he's walking the right line and the
the best way this this this is carried
out is if Greg ebbot can handle this
with the assistance of other states